اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
فتاه فلسطينيه برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه واضافت
الوزاره ان الفتاه اصيبت برصاصه في الراس
اطلقها جنود الاحتلال خلال اقتحامهم منطقه
البيادر بمدينه جنين حيث اعتقلوا ثلاثه
شبان بينهم اسرع محررون كما دارت اشتباكات
مسلحه بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال خلال عمليه الاقتحام اسفرت عن
اصابته فلسطينيين
تنضمه الينا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديري جيفارا مرحبا بك معنا اذا
اجملي لنا نتيجه هذا الاقتحام الاسرائيلي
لجنين
الطفله جنى زكارنه البالغه من العمر 16
عاما الان الحداد العام والاضراب الشامل
يشل الحياه بالكامل في جنين وضواحيها وفي
المخيم حدادا على استشهاد الطفله جنى التي
استشهدت خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال للحي
الشرقي لمدينه جنين همم
الطفله بالطبع فقدت اثارها وفق العائله
ومصادر طبيه لاكثر من ساعه وبعد انسحاب
قوات الاحتلال اكتشف امرها بانها على سطح
منزل عائلتها وانها قد فارقت الحياه نتيجه
اصابتها باصاب برصاصه مباشره بالرصاص الحي
في الراس وانا استشهدت على الفاور ولو
تمكنت العائله من الوصول اليها
والكوارده الطبيه لما كان قد وصل الحال
بهذا الشكل بالطبع اداره بالامس وفجر
اليوم اشتباكات مصلحه ع- وصفت بالعنيفه
همم عند اكتشاف مقاومين فلسطينيين لقوات
الاحتلال الذين اقتحموا تحديدا كما ذكرنا
الحي الشرقي
للمدينه همم النتيجه الاقتحام بالطبع هو
اعتقال ثلاثه فلسطينيين بدعم ان هناك
تنفيذ تخطيط لتنفيذ هجمات مسلحه كما اصيب
مواطنين اخرين بجراح مختلفه اصبح هذا
الامر محمد وكانه امر اعتيادي همم ما تقوم
به قوات الاحتلال في داخل تحديدا مدينتي
جنين ونابلس مجمل همم
نتحدث عنه خلال هذا العام
219 شهيدا فلسطينيه من بين ال 167 شهيده
في الضفه الغربيه من بين الشهداء 55 شهيدا
واكثر من سته الاف 1500 حاله اعتقال سجلت
منذ بدايه العام فجر هذا اليوم ايضا قوات
الاحتلال واصلت حملات الاعتقال على الاقل
حتى الان سجلت تسع عمليات اعتقال تركزت
معظمها في مخيم قلنديا جنوب رام الله وهو
الفاصل بين القدس ورام الله ايضا وفقا
مصادر حقوقيه فان قوات الاحتلال استهدفت
خلال اليومين الماضيين كوادر وخاصه اسرى
محررين من الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
من بينهم اسرى محررين وقيادات واا وفق ال
همم المؤسسات الحقوقيه قد يبدو ذلك نتيجه
همم استعداد الجبهه الشعبيه للاحتفال
البنت لاقتها الخامسه وال 50 رغم انه لم
يكن هناك اي حديث عن همم احتفالات ستقام
هنا في الضفه الغربيه نتيجه بالطبع
اجراءات ايه الاحتلال اذا الوضع برمته لا
زال متصاعدا
تقريبا فيه همم الضفه الغربيه لا يمر يوم
دون الحديث عن شهيد على الاقل ايه و وفقا
ايضا مؤسسات دوليه تابعه للامم المتحده
فان هذا العام لوحده ولم ينتهي حتى الان
هذا العام رغم اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع على
نهايته الا ان هذا العام هو الذي شهد كان
اكثر دمويه بحق الفلسطينيين عن العامين
الماضيين ونتذكر ان العام الماضي كان هناك
الحرب على غزه واشتعال انتفاضه الشعبيه في
كل انحاء فلسطين التاريخيه شكرا جزيلا لك
جباره المدير من رام الله